it's dr. Berg here in this short video
i'm going to show you how to get rid of
a sore throat within two minutes without
pills herbs drugs so it sound good and I
know my you might be thinking this is
too good to believe but it actually
really works and I want you to prove it
on yourself I wish I knew this back when
I had sore throats growing up I had a
them almost every four months especially
in the winter they kept coming and it's
interesting because once you get a sore
throat it keeps happening over and over
it's like a cycle this technique is all
acupressure and I developed it and I'm
going to teach you how to do it now you
can do it to yourself or you can have
someone do it and I'm going to teach you
both ways here's the principle of how it
works if you were to point to the sore
throat just pretend he doesn't have a
sore throat but let's let's say you did
he's pointing right to his adam's apple
right here and it's usually going to be
in the middle mid part of the neck and
then what happens we're going to draw a
line in the back part of his neck right
here we're going to be pressing inward
exactly on the opposite side of where
the sore throat is now why does that
work because pain and inflammation is
kind of a stuck energy that's stuck in
the front by pressing the opposite of
frees up the lymphatic system increases
the circulation increases the nerve flow
to free up through there so not only
will the sore throat go away within 1-2
minutes when doing this but you'll find
that it won't keep coming back which is
very very cool so I'm going to show you
how to do it you're going to use your
your middle finger here and your thumb
and we're going to press right on the
middle part and we're going to stabilize
the forehead and press inward like this
like a scissoring effect and you're
going to press nice and firmly now the
way you know you have the correct points
is that it's going to be very very very
tender on this back part way more tender
than where I here it's in the sore
throat and if I was going to use a tool
massage tool that I have you could also
do it on yourself you would take these
these this is a little tripod that has a
real thin area medium and then a wide
depending on how
the neck is maybe you probably want to
use the medium and on him and then we
just come right in there and we can
press in here and he'll be laying down
on a couch and you'll hit these two
points right where the sore throat is on
the opposite side okay if he's a bigger
guy he will work on these wider points
right here or a smaller person the
smaller points right here and you can
just do it like that but I'm going to
show you if I were to do it I would
press right here on my fingers and then
I'm going to ask him is this is this
tender right here and he's going to say
yes it's sore and if it's and then I'm
going to go a little bit lower okay
and what I'm going to feel is I'm going
to feel not just where he's telling me
it's tender but where it's very very
tight it's going to be very tight and
blocked on the opposite point of where
he hurts on the front part if we draw a
circle so I might want to play around
and go a little higher lower and just
find that one spot that's like really
like a rock-hard tight and then we're
going to press right into that area it
might be even more tight on the left
side or the right side and then I might
spend more pressure on that point and
then I'm going to ask him while I'm
holding this pressure I'm going to rate
it like ten being very severe zero being
no soreness give me a number he'll maybe
see says ten and then I'm going to hold
this and tell me when it goes down to a
nine eight seven six five four - until
it's zero and he you might it might
actually plateau where it doesn't move
and then I'll ask him did it move lower
- the sore throat go low or he goes yes
or higher and then I'm just going to
adjust my fingers lower or higher to
match where it hurts on the front part
so I'm going to adjust the fingers until
there is no more soreness okay so it's
going to go away and then and I wouldn't
even wait to do this till you have a
sore throat
I would do this before you had a sore
throat to prevent a sore throat it's the
easiest thing to do and you just freeing
up stuck energy flows and your neck and
if you have repetitive sore throats over
many many years it forms a lot of
tightness
in the neck so typically it's going to
be very very tight and you might have to
go lower and you press in there and
you're going to find one spot that is
the most tender of all the tender areas
and that's the one you just hold and you
might have to hold this for about two
minutes maybe a little bit longer but
that pain is going away and and what'll
happen it feel a lot better and you
might have to do it the next day or the
next day but you'll find that it's it's
the best thing to do for sore throats
because what I used to do is take
antibiotics over and over and over and
over and get better but then it would
keep coming back okay so this technique
is something that anyone can do so go
ahead and apply this and then go ahead
and click below and I'm going to give
you some download notes on a step by
step if you want to just see it in a
one-page so I have a little link below
click that and that way you can print
that out and use that the next time you
have a sore throat I'll see in the next
video